[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with the face
for marvel announcement shattering
multiverse and San Diego comic-con this
past weekend I thought I'd take a look
to the future and see what films we have
to look forward to from 2022 onwards
Kevin Feige recently revealed to Empire
magazine that the studio already has all
of phase 5 mapped out and there were
enough dropped hints during the phase 4
announcement that we have a pretty good
idea of what's to come throughout this
video I'll be breaking down every
confirmed film for phase 5 and
discussing all of the information that
we know so far about the upcoming slate
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you aren't fully up to speed with Marvel
yet and don't want anything potentially
ruined about the future films then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video
now let's get into my breakdown of the
MCU phase 5 okay so the first film of
phase 5 will in fact be blade starring
Maha shala Ali whilst this was announced
as part of the phase 4 panel baggie
later admitted that the film would in
fact take place in phase 5 this was
arguably the biggest reveal of the panel
and got a huge round of applause from
the audience of hall H upon its
announcement whilst the film won't be
around until 2022 at the very earliest
and actually believe that we will see
blade appear before then during one of
the upcoming Marvel movies the MCU has a
habit of introducing characters long
before their solo films such as
spider-man and black panther who both
made appearances in Captain America
Civil War and I think blade will
probably pop up in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness which is said to
be the first horror film in the
franchise blade would perfectly fit the
occult part of this film and though he
may not be in the main storyline it
would make sense to at least seen
appearance by the character in the
post-credits scene
at the very least next up is black
panther 2 which has been confirmed by
the casting crew to be in production
ryan coogler is currently working on the
script of the film so it looks like it's
only gonna be a matter of time before we
get an official announcement the future
film is rumored to have an appearance by
Michael B Jordan who will talk to Chara
on the spiritual
and he has been confirmed by several
sources to be returning rumors are also
circulating that we may in fact be
getting a release date for Phase five at
the Disney d23 Expo next month so make
sure you say lock to the channel for
more news on that as we get it after
that is guardians of the galaxy vol 3
now this film has had a bit of a trouble
production with James Gunn being fired
from the project after some old tweets
resurfaced no one was really willing to
step in and take over the project and
after numerous protests from the cast
and online petitions Gunn was hired back
to film the movie unfortunately Gunn now
had other commitments mainly over at DC
which is where he's working on the
upcoming film The Suicide Squad this
movie was originally slated to be
released before Thor 4 however due to
all of the aforementioned problems it's
now scheduled to release a lot later and
will probably begin filming in 2021
Marvel confirmed today that the film
will be set after the events of Thor
love and thunder and now some editing to
the initial script will be required as
it was originally meant to take place of
the back of Avengers endgame guardians
is obviously a huge property and it
could seal phase 5 is one of the best in
the studio's history if it manages to
take all of the boxes the film itself is
supposedly set around the crews
searching for Gamora who was lost at the
end of Avengers endgame
though Kevin Feige has confirmed that
she is still alive and apparently the
film will also sent her around rocking
it and covering the fact that his
creator is the High Evolutionary and
being introduced to Lyla Adam warlock is
to set to make an appearance and he will
have matured in the five years in his
part that was seen at the end of
guardians 2 so this could provide the
MCU with another huge character after
that is Captain Marvel 2 which is a film
that we don't really know all that much
about as Captain Marvel only debut this
year you can probably imagine that this
would be much later in the slate than
the other entries it's still unclear
whether the time setting of Captain
Marvel 2 will follow on from the first
film and if it will chronicle Carol
Danvers finding a new home for the
scrolls and then taking on the Kree but
there have been sources close to the
project they have said that the film
will be an adaptation of secret Wars and
we'll have Danvers at the helm this
would make more sense and a good
early so the seeds for Secret Invasion
down the line which will obviously be a
huge thing for the MCU following on from
this is the as of now untitled
spider-man 3 film which will reportedly
pick up immediately after the events of
spider-man far from home with the
titular character on the run after his
identity was exposed by Jay jonah
Jameson and Mysterio directed John
Watson star Tom Holland have both
championed Kraven the hunter to become
the next film and marbled artists boss
logic also recently posted that he had
heard Cravens origins story would tie
directly into a condor with the hunter
being a member of a long exile tribe it
was originally reported that Sony would
take back the rights of the character if
far from home Bale to gross one billion
dollars at the box office however the
movie has now surpassed this estimation
and therefore it's well on its way to
getting made Marvel have also been
heavily implying that the sinister six
will make an appearance so this could
definitely be the springboard for the
characters to be introduced the
Fantastic Four is also another big film
that was paid lip-service to in the
phase four panel and it's one of the
major properties that Disney recently
acquired in their Fox acquisition that
definitely holds a lot of potential for
the future a comic-con Kevin Feige made
it loud and clear that Marvel's first
family will play a big part in the
future of the franchise and this phase 5
movie is reportedly due to begin
production in 2022 though no cast or
director have been named yet the
Fantastic Four holds the potential to
introduce a whole host of new characters
of the MCU such as the Silver Surfer
Galactus and of course Doctor Doom who
many believe will replace Thanos as the
big bad of the MCU for the foreseeable
future I'm just gonna say it right now
if we don't get John Krasinski's mr.
fantastic then we're I err and I'm
obviously very hyped to see this
franchise done right up next is the
other big Fox acquisition property which
is the x-men though foggy didn't
out-and-out name them he did say that
there would be mutants joining the MCU
there are very little plans are in place
right now that we can go off beyond pure
speculation and rumor I believe that a
snap may have led to the existence of
mutants and this will be how they are
brought into the universe with no
mention of a release date for New
Mutants now it looks like that movie is
being shelved
we'll be wiping the slate clean so that
they can focus on getting the x-men off
to a fresh star which in my opinion is
much needed because yet Dark Phoenix
sucked
after this we could potentially get the
New Avengers Kevin Feige in an interview
over the weekend said that the next team
up we can expect will be unlike anything
that we've seen before so it's a safe
bet to assume that this will be made up
predominantly of new characters the
rumored lineup is Falcon who has become
the new Captain America spider-man
Captain Marvel a Doctor Strange and
black panther that we will see when this
comes to fruition in the future and
finally is the Dark Avengers though
there have been no real mention of these
characters so far in the MCU comic book
calm recently reported that the black
widows solo movie was set to introduce
and lay the groundwork for the film the
Elena biloba played by Florence Pugh is
set to become a dark version of widow
similar to a comic book counterpart and
David Harbor has been confirmed to be
playing Red Guardian who is a Russian
version of Captain America that could
easily fit into the team the abomination
2 has been rumored to be returning since
his appearance in the first Incredible
Hulk film and those who've watched the
Marvel one-shot called the consultant
will know that abomination was initially
being eyed by shield to take the Hulk's
place due to banner being on the run
shang-chi will introduce high level
magic to the MCU and with Doctor Strange
to dabbing into the multiverse that
could be several dark versions of the
character pulled together such as an
evil Thor Thor himself could become a
twisted version of this and this might
be why Jane Foster needs to take up his
mantle and overall there's a lot of
potential for this series in the end I
actually think that phase 5 has the
potential to be even better than phase 4
and there's so many things that were
admitted from the line of last weekend
that if put in place here will make the
biggest MCU slate ever now one thing
I've been wondering that I'm not really
seen any Marvel executives tackle is
will we eventually get complete reboot
of the universe whilst it's massively
successful the more films that get added
to the franchise the more it could
alienate new viewers I mean think about
it
let's say you're just a kid now you want
to go see some amazing superhero movies
you want to go see Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness for some strange
reason turns out though you need to go
back and watch
another 25 films or something I mean our
new fans gonna really want to go back
and do that let's say we get to face six
and there's about 40 films in the MCU
our new fans really gonna have the time
to go back and watch all of the older
movies just to get up to speed I really
don't know how Marvel's gonna handle it
but do you think in the future they
might start doing slightly disconnected
films that you can go into without any
prior knowledge just to make them more
audience friendly obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on that and this
lineup in general and if there's
anything you think will be coming up in
the movies I've mentioned or the slate
itself that make sure you comment below
and let me know we've also just dropped
a full breakdown of everything you need
to know about the phase 4 lineup so make
sure you check that breakdown out after
this it covers all of the comic-con
panel so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more and I'll
leave that linked at the end and
hopefully see you over there after this
if you want to come talk to me directly
or just want to see my general thoughts
on movies TV shows and games then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of avengers endgame on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on phase 5 in the comment
section below the one will be chosen at
random on August the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]